have you ever made spagbol french onion
soup Spanish omelette
well you've better watch out the new
frontier of identity politics is the
kitchen super chef Gordon Ramsay is in
the soup for launching his new
restaurant a lucky cat with the
following puffs authentic Asian eating
house and vibrant late-night lounge
inspired by the drinking dens of 1930s
Tokyo and the Far East but when a food
blogger went to the launch event she was
disappointed to find she was the only
Asian there she expressed her
disappointment in a spicy review for
eater London's website taking down
Ramsay for cultural appropriation I can
see why some might be annoyed at
Ramsay's claimed that his offering was
authentically Asian but panel define
authentic when it comes to food at your
peril to insist that dishes are only
prepared and marketed by the indigenous
people of its country of origin is the
real kitchen nightmare here when I hear
the words cultural appropriation
attached to the story in a multicultural
society which we do cultural
appropriation is inevitable it's stupid
to imagine we can't borrow or admire
aspects of people's cultures without
insulting them in the process Gordon
Ramsay has earned the right to open
whatever kind of restaurant he wants to
open and call it whatever he wants to
call it because you know he's a
michelin-starred chef
he doesn't mangle food together he
produces incredible food and he's right
to hit out of this you know I love the
fact that we draw inspiration from other
people's food and and and I just kind of
wonder you know what what we gain from
all this
our G bar G over cultural appropriation
I'm doing well send it I thought I
thought I'd never go don't bother we
like to tell you that does it does it
increase racial justice no no does it
does it does it increase awareness of
racist bigotry no it
and all it does is make people angry and
it device shall we see what the East
Asian food blogger actually said and
what her objections were I was the only
East Asian person in a room full of 30
to 40 journalists and chefs
it was nothing if not a real-life Ramsay
kitchen nightmare which felt more seedy
nightclubs in Asian eating house or
perhaps that is Ramsay's vision of a
vibrant authentic Asian eating house my
question maybe Karen is do you think
what the problem here is not the fact
that you have people of different
nationalities cooking food of different
nationalities to them but the use of the
words authentic and it's actually a
question of misappropriation of language
rather than of food so cultural
appropriation at the moment I think it's
political correctness gone mad because
food is also all about innovation yes
now don't we all remember the Asian
fusion restaurants now what is fusion
it is not Chinese or Thai it's
Vietnamese it's mixing it's being
innovative and what is brilliant about
our chefs we have some of the best chefs
in the world in this country is because
they're very innovative on the other
hand I mean if there if I read out what
George Chen the chinese-american chef
and restauranteur what he said is is the
famous chef going to curse at his white
cooks in Asian or what stay free chef
has a right to interpret another cuisine
but the integrity and culture needs to
be studied in depth and not whitewashed
for marketing purposes and what's with
all the lucky naming deal it's like
Charlie Chan stereotypes all over again
so the expectation if it is meant to be
authentic I mean in my business we
supply 98.5 percent of the South Asian
restaurants the teri restaurants
two-thirds of them are Bangladeshi owned
and run so do you expect in an Indian
restaurant Chi restaurant South Asian
for the chef to be Bangladeshi Pakistani
Indian Sri Lanka the Nepalese but the
reality is almost 100 percent of them
are
you know you you go to an Indian
restaurant in this country run by Indian
people chefs whatever it will take the
food will taste entirely different from
the food you get in an Indian restaurant
in India because because they're
different because they're mixing let's
just hear what God Ramsay's got to say
on this he says Gordon Ramsay's
restaurants do not discriminate based on
gender race or beliefs and we don't
expect anyone else to I may not agree
with all reviews but if somebody's going
to be critical then I expect them to be
professional and have some integrity I
think what we mustn't forget is that
food is actually the ultimate unifier
it's a really great way of connecting
with people from different cultures and
it's a great way of actually introducing
somebody to someone else's culture so
for me I have no problem with somebody
of a different ethnicity or opening a
restaurant with a culture they have
nothing to do with but what I would say
and back to the blogger's point it is
interesting we have got to the place
where we no longer credit the source of
this stuff anymore so it wouldn't have
even occurred to Gordon Ramsay that
perhaps if you're going to have an
authentic Asian restaurant maybe have a
few employees who might actually I will
thank this reagent I said he wouldn't
have even occurred to him and I do he
didn't write identic I mean I would
never ever there are genuine issues
concerning cultural and things like this
over curry restaurant over a joke an
Asian that just takes away the validity
of any real argument and let's again
there we used to be the laughingstock of
the world when it came to food yeah you
do remember the times when you went to
an Indian restaurant
what was your curry a comer was a mild
you know we are now respected around the
world with a wonderful cuisine that we
produce and a mix of all those issues
just add though I do think the thing
that I found weird about the restaurant
wasn't even so much the menu was the
name I think lucky cat is just
just going into dodgy territory and
again I do believe pod magnets I
genuinely don't know it's something
talismanic about well no you in terms of
some of some of the stereotypes or you
people sexy fish always I don't know
stereotypes around certain pets in Asian
culture there have been stereotypes and
I would have stayed away moving away
from restaurants do we think that I
think it's right having brought in this
topic that you know parmesan should be
protected and Cornish Pasties and
cheddar cheese and prosciutto and karma
ham and all those things where there it
they are come from a specific Xiaomi
action yeah they should that I think is
important to a local industry to liberal
culture and I agree that that should
remain sacrosanct but I do I'm not
remotely bothered by M&S producing a
biryani rap please I am because this is
a smirk on the founder of Darjeeling
Express and here's what she had to say
when M&S I love that rap she said this
is so wrong at Sur in so many ways at so
many levels who are you paying to design
your raps M&S you seriously need to
rethink your exotic rap selection this
is not biryani you do not appropriate
names on the cuisine without even
bothering to do any research on that
dish she does have a pleasure she is a
brilliant chef and restaurant and their
signature dish by the way we can only
make spaghetti bolognese in Bologna you
got to make your bolognaise any more
interesting you should say it spaghetti
bolognese because Carlo silly one of an
Italian chef Josie oh sorry I thank you
I stand corrected
she says this is an invented yes yes
yeah yes never came from Bologna and in
fact in Bologna they never put cream in
it or something carbonara not had
increments
and I love cooking carbonara by the way
so I'll come around you I didn't already
be there